broken bodies and minds a familiar sight
in any conflict zone but after 40 years
of war many Afghans have known only
conflict and suffering at the
International Red Cross Center in Kabul
tens of thousands of Afghan civilians
disabled by fighting have been treated
many come every day whom IRA was caught
in crossfire between government and
Taliban fighters in Faryab province a
bullet lodged in her spine leaving her
paralyzed and unable to care properly
for her two-year-old son it was a fight
I was trying to flee from my street and
this happened to me on the way I felt
the sharp shock and fell down I don't
remember what happened after that
nowhere is safe especially from suicide
bombers the capital Kabul has suffered
hundreds of attacks in the last 18 years
38,000 civilians have been killed in the
war another 40,000 have been wounded and
those numbers are rising as fighting
intensifies so far this year a record
number 4000 Afghan civilians have been
killed because of the war that's almost
70 every single day and more and more
Afghans are saying that if they had the
choice they would leave the country yet
most European governments for example
are refusing to give them sanctuary
because they don't consider Afghanistan
to be dangerous enough so people have to
endure Afghan affluent are able to
survive the hardships but an estimated
54% of the population live below the
poverty line wali Mohammad and his wife
and four children have just arrived in
Kabul after fleeing the fighting in
Helmand province he's having to build a
shelter from mud and rebuild their lives
but he's not expecting Saturday's
presidential election to bring any
improvements we need shelter water
plastic and food there are people in
this camp that don't have food for
tonight president Ghani has made
promises in the past but nothing changed
that's why many have lost belief in
elections they say they only believe in
food and survival Abdul Aziz fled to
Herat from his homing bag East province
because of heavy fighting he and his
wife and six children survive on
handouts home is now a mud hut john-boy
about my pool but the mob elections are
meaningless to us we need security we
don't
care if it's the Taliban or the
government or whoever we just need the
fighting to stop so we can go home and
start our lives again usually elections
in Afghanistan brings some kind of hope
but for many there is now only fear and
fatigue they say they are scared of the
war tired of the hardships and no
election will change that
Tony Berkeley al Jazeera Kabul